(Gunshot)
♪♪
Dad, what did you do?
-I, um...
-Allie: Shh, hey.
Around about the early mid-point
of this first season
Neil:
we begin to see the first hints
that there is more to Margot
Neil:
than meets the eye.
She's not a passenger in this
story.
♪♪
What did you tell Chuy,
about us?
Mosquito Coast came to me and I
just kept the script by my
bedside,
Melissa:
and read it over the months.
And never did a casting.
Melissa:
Because I was afraid that I
loved it too much,
Melissa:
that I didn't want to lose the
part.
So here's what's gonna happen.
Melissa:
Margot's got this killer streak
in her,
and what I wanted to show in
episode 4 especially is that
Melissa:
you can see that when things are
bad, she's like an assassin.
Melissa:
A very elegant, silent one.
I've always considered her the
patriarch of the family.
Justin:
She's the one who's probably the
most level,
Justin:
the most thoughtful and also the
most empathetic
Justin:
with the children.
I'm a mom.
Always thinking about the worst
thing that could possibly happen
to them.
Justin:
Allie is sort of this slightly
hyperactive
Justin:
bouncy child.
He's incredibly facile at
manipulating people
Justin:
as he's looking them in the
eye and being dead honest with them.
Hey, I told you it was gonna be
an adventure.
Allie exemplifies an element of
the American dream.
Neil:
Wherein that hurricane of
optimism and a forward movement
Neil:
becomes a kind of blindness
to the needs of what might be
around.
He's always thinking that the
grass is greener, because to him
it is.
And he constantly searches for
that part of life.
Neil:
In episode 4, Allie's confronted
with some truths about himself,
Neil:
and is humiliated.
Which is an element, Justin
didn't only accept, but
celebrate and pushed.
You wanna run away from
America, but you can't.
Chuy:
The way you think you can buy
people, the way you think you can buy anything you want.
You are America.
He's got this very
American, pioneer spirit, um,
we're just gonna set off
Justin:
and we're gonna find our
Shangri-La elsewhere.
Neil:
There's a tension between
optimism and theft.
In this constant need, always to
look at the next valley.
Neil:
There's always the next place to
go.
Neil:
It's always gonna be better.
♪♪